Well
[Music]
hello, how are you? Natalia Lancelot greets you
and with her brief News Now report
in Spanish, a man suspected in a
fatal accident at an event in
Wisconsin, has a criminal history in
Nevada, Dar Boots, 39, is
registered as a sexual abuser in  the
state of nevada since 2006
brooks will now appear before a judge
in wisconsin on tuesday for charges
related to the crash a motorcyclist
is dead after a crash on
highway 95 near the
ranch drive exit the
nevada highway and highway patrol said  it
hit a wall the driver died at the
scene holiday shopping is on the
rise and this means more
people are on the lookout to get
hold of it to combat this
problem the metro police will be
covertly patrolling the streets plus the  Officers
will be casually dressed in
areas that are normally targets for
robbery to protect themselves from a  Any thieves
remember to park in
well-lit areas and not leave
valuables inside your
vehicle once inside the store don't
leave your bag and other belongings out
of sight while shopping
plan to go straight home once
you're done  finished and now we turn to
the weather forecast we will see some
clouds however we will be with a
maximum of 70 degrees by the afternoon
the winds will return to the valley and this
will cause the temperatures to drop for
Thursday yes yes Thanksgiving
and for the  Friday also awaits us a
sunny weekend beautiful day
greets you Natalia Lancelot and with her brief
informative hymns NOW in Spanish